una partícula se mueve a lo largo de una
recta su velocidad es inversamente
proporcional al cuadrado de la distancia
s que ha viajado que ecuación describe
esta relación bueno ni siquiera voy a
ver estas opciones porque voy a tratar
de analizar la oración y ver si podemos
proponer una ecuación entonces nos dicen
que su velocidad
esto es importante es inversamente
proporcional al cuadrado de la distancia
ok
dice que la distancia se llama ese
entonces vamos a ponerle nombre ese va a
ser la distancia entonces dejemos
escribirlo y si esa es la distancia
entonces cómo podemos escribir a la
velocidad bueno la velocidad es la tasa
de cambio de la distancia con respecto
al tiempo déjame escribirlo la velocidad
sería la tasa de cambio de la distancia
con respecto al tiempo ok esto de aquí
representan
velocidad así que tenemos que bajo
nuestra anotación la derivada de la
distancia con respecto al tiempo es la
velocidad y por otra parte podemos decir
que esto de aquí tiene que ser
inversamente proporcional al cuadrado de
la distancia es justo lo que me dice el
problema así que vamos a escribirlo la
velocidad que es la tasa de cambio de s
con respecto al tiempo esto es
inversamente proporcional y por lo tanto
aquí voy a escribir una constante de
proporcionalidad esto va a ser
inversamente proporcional a la distancia
elevada al cuadrado entonces a ese
elevado al cuadrado perfecto aquí lo
tenemos esta va a ser la ecuación
diferencial porque observa es una
ecuación diferencial que en realidad
está describiendo nuestra oración que
tendríamos aquí arriba entonces veamos
cuál de las opciones nos dice justo esto
y si observamos es la cuarta opción la
cuarta opción dice esto
de lo mismo que nosotros acabamos de
escribir exactamente lo mismo que lo que
nosotros llegamos la velocidad es
inversamente proporcional a la distancia
elevada al cuadrado perfecto ahora sólo
para asegurarnos de que entendemos estas
otras opciones vamos a interpretarlas la
primera opción esta de aquí me está
diciendo que la distancia que es una
función del tiempo es inversamente
proporcional al tiempo al cuadrado lo
cual no era lo que nos estaban diciendo
aquí cierto la segunda opción también me
habla de la distancia como una función
del tiempo y nos dice que ésta es
inversamente proporcional al cuadrado de
la distancia o que ésta es demasiado
extraña nada que ver con lo que
estábamos viendo esta si habla de la
velocidad de la tasa del cambio con
respecto al tiempo pero nos dice que es
inversamente proporcional al tiempo al
cuadrado y nosotros queremos que sea
inversamente proporcional al cuadrado de
la distancia así que es por eso que nos
quedamos y que nos gusta esta cuarta
opción